[Music]
so welcome to section 37 in the worlds
of speculative fiction series it's all
old hands here so I don't have to go
through any of that stuff that we
normally do and today we're talking
about Gordon Dixon's Doris I or a child
series of novels so what we always do is
a bit of biographical stuff you want to
jump into that right away or should we
jump into the world-building what do you
think okay oh yeah yeah so he's you know
in a ways he's a interesting transplant
because he starts out in Canada but he
becomes Americanized so so quickly his
father dies when he's quite young and
his mother moves him to Minneapolis and
that's more or less where he stays most
of his life apart from you know there's
his stint in the US Army during World
War two so you know that by itself would
be I suppose enough to sort of make him
fully US American and Canadians could
contest you know what's the third
American as well and you know he goes to
the University of Minnesota apparently
he was there when Sinclair Lewis was
also in the writing program so they must
have exchanged some some interesting
things you know nobody's really fully
formed a program though right and you
notice there's not an awful lot of
biographical things to say about it he
you know went to science fiction cons a
lot he got a lot of awards he fairly
early in his his career became a
professional writer so I think that's
that's kind of a contrast to many of the
people who we've been looking at so far
where their careers wouldn't take off
for them like think about philipose a
farmer where
he couldn't get anything paid for for a
long time and only could become a
professional writer later on so by 1950
he has his first story co-written with
Paul Anderson published in fantastic
story quarterly and then he follows that
up the next year in astounding with the
friendly man and I only only listed his
novels but you can see that there's you
know a number of them and I highlighted
the ones that are part of the the door
size series and you can see there
they're really quite spread out and many
of them you know we've talked about this
in the past about the fix-up phenomenon
where you take a short story and then
you kind of build it out you know he
then Voight was really well known for
that so it looks like Dixon did that
with with quite a few of these as well
but then eventually the the door sire
child series it took out a very very
vast structure that was never completely
seen through largely because of Dixon
dying so he had plans for developing it
much further
but but it never was able to be realized
so we'll talk about some of that that
scope in a bit you notice that he's you
know I didn't put in all the awards that
he gets but he gets quite a few of them
we were talking before about the dragon
series as well
he's turning those the dragon on the
George's early on but then in the 90s
he's turning them out fairly regularly
in the thing and he's got all sorts of
other series he did quite a few
collaborative works with other authors
not just Paul Anderson but but some
others as well so there isn't that much
to say about his his biography it's not
like he he appears to
had a lot of ups and downs the way many
of our other authors did and he one of
the things I did find that was kind of
interesting is there there's a continent
I think it's from any kind a science
fiction yeah have you ever gone to that
yeah he I guess he was instrumental in
getting it underway because he was he
was there you know and the Hamptons
papers up at the University of Minnesota
boxes and boxes and boxes of them I
think it would be kind of interesting to
to find out about him it's not that far
and as a matter of fact I should mention
so next month were we're doing somebody
who's even closer August Derleth
you know from Wisconsin but you know
Dixon apparently spent a good bit of
time in Wisconsin and I haven't checked
it out yet but he wrote some poems and
some some pieces that are you know
mostly about like you know Wisconsin and
Minnesota and the landscape so those
those might be interesting to to see so
let's jump right into this this vast
world series the handout that I created
for this is basic you know it's very
rudimentary and it's just showing the
different planets that are in this what
would we call it the expansion of
humanity into the the stars and like a
lot of other authors he doesn't have us
jumping immediately to the edge of the
galaxy or anything like that it's all
the closest star systems that we could
we could get into and the reason why all
of these matter is because in the the
universe that he creates the narrative
universe humankind has changed by going
out to the Stars and you know we see
this in other authors like
we've talked about recently like CH air
CJ chera
where we it takes us a while to get to
places we establish colonies those
colonies to establish their their own
sort of basis I think you could say here
slike that green is like that too with
their Hainish novels and then the
question is well what becomes of us what
becomes of humanity and in I found it
really useful to have this book there's
three to d'Orsay edition because it's
got some of the door side novels
arranged in the chronological sequence
rather than that the sequence that he
wrote them so the first one is this
necromancer board and that takes place
on earth and it takes place in the 21st
century the extent in time of the whole
series is well in a way the extensive
part of the whole series is out to the
24th century and man came is actually
expanding pretty quickly through through
the cosmos they they discover faster
than light drives of course which is you
know a necessity of stellar travel that
means anything and you're not just using
colony ships but this was nice because
it he had necromancer in it and then
tactics of mistake which which is like
the second one that he wrote yeah you're
right
so I didn't highlight d'Orsay that's
right so it's a fourth so door size
first which was originally the genetic
general then necromancer then soldier
asked not then tactics of mistake so
those are all in the same time period
later on he's getting into these these
others but it's nice because they're
arranged in a sequence and there's some
like speculative stuff in between them
sandwiched in there
what the the storyline was supposed to
be about and so necromancer is a good
one to start with the world-building is
happening I guess you could say through
elaborating what humanity is turning
into on these different worlds so as a
matter of fact we should wish this would
be a good place to jump into one of the
big philosophical themes because I think
it'll make sense out of the world
building so the he talks in terms of
splintering and he uses the term racial
instinct quite a bit in this but he
doesn't he doesn't mean race in terms of
the races that we typically think of he
means that means the human race breaking
itself into different groups and so I
guess the place to start with that is at
the end of necromancer so humanity is is
kind of in a bind they're they're going
out to the stars going to different
places and establishing new ways of
living each each colony is drawing in
people attracted to a certain type so
earth remains what what he calls broad
spectrum humans like you at you and I
where we have a whole bunch of different
traits all kind of rolled in we're kind
of you know messy contradictions because
we might have one you know more
predominating than the other if if in
our life we have one thing totally
dominating us we become model maniacs
we wind up going insane or you know
getting in charge of something and
creating terrible catastrophes that way
but in these colonies when they go out
they draw in these personality types or
you could call them also spiritual
aspects of humanity and each one is able
to develop along its own line so if you
look at the different different worlds
the door sigh are the the military world
they become the finest mercenaries it's
it's largely a water world and they you
know they're trained from from infancy
basically to the super soldiers they
follow a very strict code of conduct
they they're a decentralized government
that split over a number of different
you know power centers and you know
they're they're associated with this
very martial culture so it represents
the you know in a way it's almost
platonic right this courageous thematic
aspect of human beings that played on
the Republic talks about some of us are
naturally more spirit driven than others
and those are the ones you want for your
soldiers and and warriors and the door
side become this this military force of
mercenaries who are you know more or
less unstoppable compared to other
soldiers and it's actually speculated
that if they decided to they could
actually take over all the worlds new
earth it also remains like old earth
full spectrum so it's people like like
us Mercury and Mars they don't really
play much of a role in the stories
because they're they are colonized but
they're not effectively colonized to
where they can become independent worlds
and then you get all these other things
like free land which is colonized mostly
by Northern Europeans and
it's you know associated with hard work
ethic
lots of bureaucracy it attracts that
that's sort of officious type Dutton's
world is largely fishermen there's not
that much to say about that Kobe is a
mining world that doesn't have it was
never terraformed they build underground
it's also kind of a place where you know
the mob can can run things criminal
organizations workers don't always have
it to to great Sant Marie which is which
is in the same area as the exotics gets
settled and I don't remember the
explanation but it gets settled by a
bunch of Catholics and they they set
themselves up as farmers so they're
providing agricultural products to
people
Kenny is is a commercial world you know
trading and and engaging in some
manufacturing as well and then you got
these three these three other
associations that are particularly
important I mean you could say like
Kenny okay the commercial aspect and you
know the the little Adam Smith in each
of us right that could be the archetype
for for that but you've got these other
three that are that are really important
in the story and I'll come to the two
that are more important later first
let's talk about the hard sciences
worlds so Venus gets settled and in the
process of settlement you get all these
people who are primarily interested in
either the sciences or the applications
of the sciences going out there and
living a life together so it's sort of
like a colony well I mean it is a colony
I'm saying it's sort of like when we
hear on this world we have colonies of
people who have those sorts of you know
I can imagine we took NASA and all the
science departments of our universities
and what else would we stick in there
yeah very good yeah Silicon Valley and
we just sort of threw them all together
into one big group and said okay go to
it so Venus and Newton those are the
ones that are really specializing in the
sciences and such and you know
apparently like Newton the best
physicists come from there
because that's where the best schools
are and so it kind of makes sense and
then caseta is where the technicians
come from the technicians of the
engineers so there's kind of a split in
between there the theoretical of the
applied right or the theoretical and the
practical and it produces people who see
the world through the lens of the hard
sciences rather than you know the social
sciences or the humanities or anything
like that
the Friendly's and almost everybody who
comments on it says you know totally
incorrectly named given what happens in
the stories the friendlies are settled
by these people who are primarily
interested in practicing their religion
and they could be very very nice sort of
faith oriented people with strong
spiritual life or they can be complete
fanatic jerks and everything in between
and on the two worlds of the Friendly's
there there's all these different
churches that fight with each other but
they're also within an association as
well and each of the worlds produces
something so you know from from caseta
you get all sorts of technical products
coming on right or from Sansa Murray
you've got all these agricultural
products the friendlies they're kind of
a poor set of worlds the farming that
they do is just substance farming for
themselves they don't produce much their
main export is soldiers so they're kind
of like in the same boat as the door
side except the door Sykes will export
high-quality soldiers who are trained to
you know
think about the best tactics and
minimize casualties and maximize their
effectiveness the friendlies sell
cannon-fodder because you know they're
there people are filled with faith and
they can tell them well then they tell
them things like you know there's
there's victory and there's death and
death really doesn't matter so just go
out there and fight and so they they
sell their their soldiers all over the
place the exotics get their start at the
end of the the necromancer book and
they're there what the original Chantry
guild in that book are a bunch of people
who are interested in philosophy but not
you know just like the history of
philosophy there and as a matter of fact
you know we were talking about that that
PPE program you know philosophy or
politics economics imagine taking that
because with the the so philosophy and
and let's say instead of economics it
was philosophy politics in psychology
right and then add some some more
esoteric stuff into it that has to do
with manipulating unseen forces so
there's a kind of an occult part to it
but but it can be understood in terms of
psychology and then you've got the
exotics the exotics are these people who
are specialized in that aspect I guess
the the other humanities would kind of
fit in there to the fine arts and stuff
like that an appreciation for that and
then the friendlies really don't get
along because the friendlies view them
as just a bunch of heretics and godless
people that are always there trying to
occupy the same spiritual space in a way
you know and so you've got already some
rivalries between these and the way that
Dixon sets up his sort of grand story
you've got all sorts of individual
characters who are coming out of these
world
and representing their their types but
it's also sort of like you know the
humanity goes out fans out into all
these different groups and and the the
archetypes or whatever you want to call
them aspects of humanity are also
struggling with each other through the
medium of worlds and warfare and
economics and and all of that sort of so
so it's you know it's pretty vast
conception that's going on and it
happens through a narrative where you
know colonization you know goes out and
and occurs that way and originally so
we'll come back to the the theme of
what's happening in necromancer and in
the next main book the tactics of a
mistake and some of the associated
things earth still is playing a major
role and the other colony worlds haven't
become completely independent of Earth's
interference yet and Earth is playing a
major role in part because earth is
still divided between two main power
alliances one is called the Alliance and
one is called the coalition and it's
supposed to be like you know west and
east so you've got like presumably
America and Europe and maybe South
America and maybe Japan or something
like that in the Alliance and then
you've got the coalition and then they
get they get they you know they play
proxy wars on these planets and then
you've got also the door psy slowly
establishing themselves as some of the
best commanders and and and soldiers but
they haven't completely broken away and
the the sort of story arc of of that
through the character Donald Graham is
to find a way for the door side to
actually become independent and begin
offering a third option for for all
these governments to hire instead of
having to be part of Earth's orbit you
could say
so through either belonging to to either
being a coalition coalition a liar being
an alliance ally and so that that ends
up you know reducing the the the role of
earth in many respects in the later
books but it also ends up allowing all
these other groups to to spiral off and
become their their own thing so this is
to go to go back to this this
splintering you know if you think about
it in terms of philosophical themes like
in our in our society well really going
back throughout politics and philosophy
one of the key ideas has been division
of labor right specialization you can
think of it in terms of like Plato and
you know three parts of the city and
three parts of the soul as it's usually
got to be more complicated than that but
you know in Aristotle in the politics
you get a much more complicated
arrangement and but there there is
specialization and specialization tends
to produce different or maybe not
produce but reward certain human types
certain modes of behavior so academics
are different kind of people than
farmers are different kind of people
than mechanics are different kind of
people than city administrators and and
so on so when humanity is going out into
the void and and landing on these
planets what's what Dickson portrays us
as being is not just sort of some
contingent
historical development of you know well
they they just happen to find that you
know mechanics worked well for them you
know or this this is a mining planet so
therefore the Sun Geographic determinism
right instead it's it's different parts
of humanity needed to go off and find
their own place to develop in their own
way so that they could develop further
than they would be able to in an
interdependent matrix on earth like that
you know the friendly is with their
their exploration of faith or the door
side with their exploration of what it
means to be militaristic and courageous
or the exotics with with you know their
philosophical development and so he
frames this in terms of through the
through the models of his characters
particularly through those of the
exotics who are kind of the brains
behind what's going on as an
evolutionary development so humankind is
becoming more than what it was becoming
different than what it was by no longer
being one single they're still one
single human race they can interbreed
they can understand each other but
they've become very different kinds of
humans adapted to different
circumstances and but still carrying on
commerce with each other so it's still
carrying out some sort of engagement
with each other and so that's that's
where it's going in the mid part of the
story and then there's some developments
later on where there's this this
realization that as humanity goes
further into the cosmos it needs to take
these now not completely isolated but
you know separated parts of itself and
breed them back into each other and so
producing a human being a human race
that would be more Hardy
and more universe oriented than the
others are who could be a little
short-sighted
so I thought one of the interesting
philosophical questions that this raises
is a kind of ethical question is it you
know is it good or bad in general to
separate out these different aspects of
what it means to be human I mean we do
it already right
in the way that we specialize in labor
and we have some cultures and things
like that but here we're talking about
entire worlds is that is that a good
thing for humans as a race or is it a
hyper specialization that in some some
ways disconnects us from our humanity
and then one of the characters in
soldiery asked now that the central
character he actually tries to engineer
the destruction of the Friendly's he
tries to he thinks it would be better to
wipe out an entire part of or an entire
aspect of humanity so if you think about
this if we put aside Dixon for a minute
and you think about like our own
character traits take you know
acquisitive competitiveness for example
the sort of thing that lies behind our
commercial enterprises and interests
would it be good for us to bring that
part of ourselves out into the open and
then get rid of it you know
what do you think I mean psychotherapy
in a way or also virtue ethics and
spiritual direction isn't isn't part of
that about like figuring out which parts
of ourselves we want to keep in which
parts we want to get rid of so if we
could do that with not just us
individually but like the whole human
race
what parts would we want obviously we
want to keep the door psyche because we
all like warriors right and the hard
scientists they're very smart so let's
keep them but I mean are there parts of
ourselves that need you know they like
it I think it's kind of an open question
do we want religious fanaticism the
tendency towards that sort of thing to
be part of our future
or it would be better if we could
actually bring that out of ourselves and
then get rid of it well yeah that's
that's very true but there's others who
want to keep it around to the the
exotics think that it's important to
have all these different parts because
then when they're bred back in if you
were to like so you isolate them out
right you eliminate some and then you
put it back together it's not going to
be the same whole it's not going to be
as fully developed I think we would tend
to think it's great isolate the stuff
out get rid of the crap and then bring
it back together and you're gonna have
an even better human being the exotics
don't see it that way they think that
it's important to have all of the all
the aspects of the human being or else
you're not you're not healthy
in some respect so that's that's one key
thing another one that actually I
mentioned you know we would come back to
this key idea that that's there in the
encyclopedia or in the necromancer one
the the beginning of necromancer and
really most of the the story there's a
there's a vast technological apparatus
running the world on earth you can think
of it as an ensemble of logistics and
you know science technology it's aided
by a vast AI which is capable of
projection rational decision-making has
a lot of forces at its disposal and the
idea is that it's going to benefit
humanity right by making our is it sort
of like giving us a post-scarcity
economy right and that the question is
well what what is the what is the status
of human beings like and if we put aside
Dixon's depiction of it and we just
imagine a situation like that like you
know where we might be heading if things
don't go off kilter like let's say
global warming doesn't kill us and you
know maybe the reforestation thing that
people are talking about now maybe
that'll fix it you know and we find some
political solution that gets us away
from fossil fuels and and maybe that you
know we we rework the economic and
political system so the AI that's
clearly coming at us and robotics and
all that winds up benefiting although
all of us not just you know whoever
happens to own the the tech companies or
factories or or you know logistics
companies or things like that what
people really be happy or not you know I
mean I know I would be happy to not have
to not have to scramble for four jobs
you know as sort of a contractor you
know teaching as an adjunct having
clients and stuff like that if I knew
that I had a steady stream that would
assure me that like all my needs would
be taken care of so I can eat what I
want I can travel what I want health
care is provided would also really want
to throw in their access to to you know
if I want to forfeit I can get it
wherever I'd be pretty happy because I
would still continue doing the kinds of
things that I do because I find
intrinsically you know I intrinsically
desire to study philosophy and talk
about it right but what would most
people do I mean you'd you'd keep doing
what you're you well I don't know would
you keep doing exactly what you're doing
here and spend more time on them and go
deeper into them yeah yeah
so there's more walks yeah well that's
yeah so that's what I was thinking
there's there's the entertainment aspect
right you can and then the video games
are getting you know vaster and vaster
and more complicated you can easily lose
yourself in a video game for months at a
time I would think 10 years from now I
mean I was talking about this with with
somebody who's around my age and I was
saying do you remember those crappy
Atari systems that we had you know and
it came with the cartridge that just had
the planes and the tanks and how we
could sit there for hours
looking at this this stupid crappy video
game and some people would actually get
drawn into it get addicted to it even
back then there are even people who got
addicted to pong which was awful you
know and now the video games are so much
more
well thought out there's you know
musicians that are hired just to produce
the wonderful scores and you know
there's like they hired storytelling
people to figure out narratives and all
that and then you know ten years from
now it's going to be even better so
maybe we maybe that's that's what
happens with a lot of people they just
kind of like consume tell me more about
that it's the vision statistically there
should be more advanced civilizations
yeah one favor where people have gone I
think the context in which I've heard of
it have usually been joking or they're
like you know maybe aliens that are out
there all over the place but they they
see the transmissions that we're sending
out they're like we don't want to be
associated with these jokers yeah maybe
that well then you could imagine all
sorts of have sort of societal
evolutionary paths that would be in
effect dead ends because if you're not
reaching out further in two important
respects you're not going to continue to
develop one would be to engage with the
physical environment more and that you
know that's challenging enough right all
we have to do is get out of a game world
and actually like go walk in lap MP Park
and and you know see stuff that's that's
way beyond what minecraft or anything
can provide us with
and you know look at it and just check
it out to know that there's there's
something there and so if we're talking
about like space exploration I mean
think about how the vast possibilities
but more important that I think would be
contact with other intelligent life
because it would present such a
challenge all right I mean we have a
hard time even figuring out what the
hell we are as human beings and how to
engage with each other imagine that we
we meet another species you know and
they're not just like in Independence
Day wanting to take our water and kill
all of us or something like that they
actually are interested in who we are
when our background is and exchanging
information and stuff like that
that would be they would be occupying us
for generations so a culture that
evolved into just being as you're saying
hedonistic wouldn't wouldn't they
wouldn't die as such but in a way it's
it's sort of moribund it's it's a dead
end
the way to develop is by doing more and
going further which that could bring you
into conflict as well which and that's
what part of where I was going with this
is in this the first story of human
beings it's not enough for them to be
entertained all the time some of them
they're cool with that some of them are
fine with having like you know
productive sort of almost like George
Jetson kind of jobs where you push the
button everything's laid out for you
your job is not very challenging or if
it is the challenges have been built in
so they they give you some spice but
other people participate in religious
cults because that gives them some
meaning there's some sort of
transcendent thing and then others
participate in these marching societies
where they they sort of mindlessly run
through the streets just destroying
things and
you know there's other possibilities too
we could imagine people becoming members
of fight clubs doing things that would
somehow stimulate them and I think that
this is a big problem we're facing now
if we if we do end up with a
post-scarcity society do we end up with
human beings unable to really
productively manage that that condition
and would they just be content with the
hedonistic lifestyle like sort of
Nietzsche's Last Man or would they need
some excitement and need to break things
you know so in in this it becomes a moot
point because the computer there's
another wrinkle to it as well the
computer realizes that we human beings
are irrational and the best way to deal
with that the whole vast world system
would be to minimize the freedom of
human beings to turn us into as you know
close to like circuits as possible so
there's there's a bit of the the Machine
you know running away and becoming the
enemy of humanity as well but it ends up
being a moot point because the Machine
ends up getting supplanted by the main
character and some of the other people
involved and that's when they start
doing the fanning out of across the
world or the universe which you know you
know in a way it's sort of like I mean
it's not that that different from
saydoun you know where you've got the
the thinking machines and then the
reaction against them and you've got
humanity in all these different places
although dude and there's like you know
tens of thousands of years of back
history before that human humans have
been out in the stars
for as long as anyone can remember
whereas this is you know it's fairly
recent but you know this this opposition
to being reduced to cogs in the machine
is kind of an interesting philosophical
point I think what do you have any
thoughts about that or further thoughts
okay
another thing that comes up in this is
you know you know we talk about the
great man theory of history sometimes
and it could be great women too or great
great whatever and I think a lot of
narratives work that way especially
especially when there is something I
reminded the foundation right so Asimov
has Harry Selden he's got this what was
the the name of the discipline that they
used psychohistory yeah and it was
predictive it would be this new
discipline that would be able to take
human beings as aggregates and predict
how economic trends would go and where
conflicts will arise it's so predicted
that you can even like create a vast
planet well the the exotics develop
something like that they call it Otto
genetics and it's very similar to I
think it's I think it's psychohistory
it's very similar to that you could
predict in general how things are going
to go but there's some individuals those
were the differences there's some
individuals who are more or less passive
nodes within the whole network and more
active and they can't be predicted as
well and they tend to be associated with
these different splinter cultures so you
know for example the newsman in soldier
ask he is one of those those characters
and so so are the dwarfs I characters as
well and the the the exotics just kind
of hang around these people and try to
you know push them the right way so that
they're still part of the the plan but
they realize that they can't fully
determine them and so you know it's kind
of it's kind of an interesting idea
about human agency and the implication
of it would be that most people maybe
even all of their life or at least part
of their life are not really free
they're not really making important
decisions between different options
they're they're going to follow along of
course only the people who really affect
human history and in important ways
unpredictable ways would be free I don't
know if that's the right way to read
this but it but it seems like that would
be one one risk of having a discipline
like that you know you got like the vast
panorama of human beings all interacting
with each other and then if that's the
case they may as well be computers right
or NPCs right and then you've got the
the player characters who are actually
doing stuff that changes the script at
least for a while
you know and some of them are thinking
very strategically you know
and at some of them are you could say
they're contending against each other so
you've got this guy William who wants to
who wants to take over the human system
he wants to take over the entire human
domain he wants to have all the worlds
under him he is from caddy and he's he's
like pulling strings here and there and
his opposition is another one of the
Grahams who out you know outmaneuvers
him over years and years and years so
but I don't what do you what do you
think about that sort of you know we
could call it the great human view of
history what would that mean to be
predicted they're there they're
unpredictable but only within certain
parameters that you'd be able to figure
out that
okay so the tech friends called yeah the
the super outliers right yeah you know
that's an interesting thing it's not
really explored in these works as far as
I can think of but any predictive system
that's that's based on I have some sort
of metrics
there's insofar as it's not the same
thing as the universe that you're trying
to predict there's always some things in
the universe that that tend to go
against it that you didn't account for
it and sometimes the difference is you
know small enough where you're like that
approximates it good enough right but
then sometimes those approximations the
they can get bigger and bigger and
bigger and you can't you because you
don't know enough about how the universe
precisely works you can't you can't be
confident that your margin of error
really is your margin of error right you
know I remember when I was when I was
studying mathematics and I I took a
province dance class for the for the
first time and I was fascinated with the
theory of probability it's really quite
cool you know when you get into it and
they're tired and they there's all this
stuff about confidence intervals you
know and that's where they stopped and
they're like well is how you calculated
this is you know is what you do to get
to this place and then I was you know
this is how I could time as a
philosopher aside well what underlies
that you know what gives you enough
confidence about the confidence interval
that you've got how do you know that you
couldn't be like totally off and they
would just look at me like I was crazy
you know because they they didn't want
to achieve effect yet so you know here's
another thing that's connected with this
great human theory which I guess you
know if you're gonna write a narrative
and you want the characters to be
compelling you probably got a end or
something like that
I mean to go back to the foundation
stuff right
is there any character in there where
you're like man I really love that
character other than like maybe the mule
who is a standout you know or are the
characters basically just there for a
couple chapters to drive the plot
where's our galactic
so in not in the very first stuff but
but later on as humanity is starting to
like ideally come back together there's
this character of the responsible man
which is the phrase that they use Dixit
uses for it and the responsible man is
going to bring together these three
aspects or disciplines from the door
side so you got the military courage and
then the exotics philosophy but then the
third one is the friendlies the faith or
fanaticism part and somehow they
integrate these and the idea is that
they're there this person is the one who
like can can decide for Humanity where
they ought to go because they fully
integrated these and you wonder well why
not also like the hard sciences you know
or I don't know maybe the farmers should
have something to say about it or the
you know the work ethic yeah but it's
it's those three that Dixon keeps going
back to over and over again courage
wisdom and faith and I don't I have to
have been I don't I don't fully
understand why those three I understand
why the characters say that those three
are particularly important I don't
understand why the other stuff should be
left out why those three should be most
directive and and I guess I'm not enough
of a plate inist where I don't have a
problem with the exotics of the
philosophy part or the door side part
but why do you need religious fanaticism
or at least the danger of religious
fanaticism to to bring these together I
have to admit I don't fully get that
well that's that's an interesting point
so they kind of do right I mean there's
a kind of courage that comes with it but
like Aristotle talks about this the the
person who doesn't feel fear when they
want to feel fear they're not really
brave right there there's something else
they could be like insensible to dangers
and there there's a you know for
Aristotle to there's there's a certain
it's almost like there's a certain
failure of humanity and being that brave
whereas the courageous person they're
where they ought to be they're fully
realizing human nature for edixon some
of the Friendly's they're there I mean
there's a excesses there's there's ones
who are fanatics in the sense that they
will throw themselves into battle
there's also some who are fanatics in
the sense that they will you know do
they don't they don't care about other
human beings as human beings because
they're like well they're not part of
our religion and they're not chosen
screw you know let's kill the prisoners
I don't know I this is something I still
have to think more more about myself
yes yeah so in soldier AFT not
forgetting the name of the so there's
this guy Tam he's that he's the main
character and he's he's a flawed
character unlike the other characters in
the books up to that point he's sort of
a he winds up at the right place at the
end but but his trajectory across the
whole thing is that he wants to he wants
to become part of this news guild
because that way he can avoid being
under contract to anybody which
talk about contracts and just a bit
swollen he'll be free and he can go
anywhere in the universe and then he
he's got a sister who at first gets
engaged to a guy from the friendlies and
I'm forgetting his name but I think it's
like Jay Mithen or something like that
and he tells her that she shouldn't
marry him that she's not gonna be happy
on the friendlies and so she breaks it
off and he goes back and becomes a force
commander which is kind of like a
low-level thing and then she marries a
guy from another planet and that that
guy gets called up on military duty and
so this guy Tam is is going around and
you know covering story after story
rising in the organization he finds that
he's all he's he's a person who can
easily manipulate people he can tell
what most people except for the the you
know the sort of almost superhumans who
run history
everybody else he can sort of figure out
what makes them tick and say the right
thing to get them to do what he wants to
give the information up and all that and
so he goes he goes out to cover the war
that's going on that this guy's been
been conscripted for and he pulls him
out of the lines and has him be his
assistant he's not able to get him a
safe passage from the other side which
is the friendlies to the friendlies are
acting as mercenaries on that world of
that conflict and what ends a large
story short they get captured the
friendly commander executes all the
prisoners and so Tam now hates the
friendlies he also gets shot the knees
so you know screws up his knee and stuff
like that
and its crew to screwed up his
relationship with his sister later on in
another conflict that he's covering he
meets back up with this first fiancee
and he talks he has a lot of dialogue
with him and quite a bit of it as you
know like your religion is [ __ ] you
know but this guy is portrayed as being
sort of like a genuinely faith-filled
person who embodies the better parts of
the faith you know and he ends up dying
and the reason the odds of dying is is
essentially to save his troops there
they're left behind on this planet
they're not going to be reinforced by
the other friendly forces and he he
organizes a parley with this d'Orsay
general one of the Grahams and general
commander of some sort and then
deliberately he and his four men who
come along they draw their weapons and
attack the door side knowing that the
door size reflexes are going to be so
good he's going to kill all of them and
this this action which violates the
mercenaries code and in certain ways
what it does is it ensures that his
troops are going to instead of just
being mowed down or something like that
they're gonna they're gonna be allowed
to surrender and go back to to the
friendlies and he's portrayed as by
Dixon at least in that as having sort of
is this you know confidence that that
his faith gives him that allows him to
be able to pull something like that off
so that's a that's an example of
somebody who's you know the good side of
of that faith oh it mentions four
contracts contracts are the way that
individuals and world's you could say
relate to each other and you're under
like if you're a mercenary right you
have a contract and somebody owns your
contract and in in many of the worlds
there's a there's a division between
what they call the loose contract worlds
and I forget exactly whether it's tight
or another word for it but the basic
idea is on some worlds like the science
world and caddy and the friendlies your
contract can be bought and sold many
times very easily is it sort of like
there's an open market for it and the
world can tell you to go somewhere and
so think of the contract as a way way in
which either government or some other
entity can order you around and tell you
what to do with allegiances on other
worlds like the door sign the exotics
frail and and new earth contracts are
loose meaning that there's a lot of it's
very difficult to like just buy up
somebody else's contracts and and take
them away there's there's much more
agency on the part of the contractor to
get to decide what they they want to do
and there's there's actually a struggle
between the worlds about well how are
contracts going to be interpreted and
then they come to some compromises about
that in one of the books so if you're
like a door sigh you're from a world
that allows you a lot of latitude about
who you will contract with once you've
contracted your stock right so if your
employer contracts with you for this
military campaign and you decide you
don't like that military okay well
you're stuck
you can't get out of it that way you
have to fulfill what your contract
requires but they can't just like sell
your contract to somebody else which is
what they can do for the friendlies so
the people who are the friendlies you
know they're really you know the world
can sell their contracts to whoever they
want it can be bought and sold many
times you can find yourself going all
over the little human part of the cosmos
without much agency of your own but you
wouldn't you wouldn't really care
because you think the church has got
things right so you're not gonna you're
not gonna worry about it too much so
that's I mean it's kind of an
interesting way of thinking about social
relations I suppose in part I mean
there's there's a lot of sort of you
know typical sci-fi hand-wave Hecht
where he's not gonna go into I mean if
you did go into great detail about it it
probably would be kind of kind of dry I
imagine right I think you know that's a
good question where did he get this idea
of contract from servitude for the
friendlies that's definitely like that
you know I mentioned too it's a way in
with worlds are related to each other so
the friendlies main export is human
cannon fodder and those those humans are
being and they're all males - there are
their bait their contracts are being
sold to fight in conflicts off because
in each world there's usually some
people in conflict with each other their
contracts are being sold and then the
money is going to the world it's not
going to the the family or the person or
something like that the world is using
that to then buy products from from
the world's the ones that have loose
contracts it's you know it's you at
you're not an indentured servant you are
somebody who's decided to sign up with
this or that and so there's more human
dignity you could say you know the the
miners on Kobe their contracts at one
point really suck and then you know
there's a revolt and then they're there
they're better you know so you the
conditions of contracts can be can be
quite different and you could find
yourself like like if you're a door sign
you could be on any one of these worlds
as part of the guard or military command
and your military command might be
commanding local troops you know or
supplementing the local troops if you're
a friendly your they they all go more or
less together they don't usually have
d'Orsay in charge of them so yeah and
these were all like fundamentally
different ways of life the other another
theme I wanted to talk about was was the
inescapability of politics
each of these worlds has to be
economically connected with the other
worlds because none of them are none of
them are totally self-sufficient I mean
some of them could be like you know the
farming world could be self-sufficient
in terms of farming they need other
stuff from other people and there's
probably something too not just an
economic thing but if you think about
humanity going out into the void and
having colonies in different places it
would be really traumatic I think for a
world to be entirely cut off from the
rest of the human cosmos you know you
wouldn't want to be totally on
even if you even if you really like the
carrot the sort of character type that
you represent you know I think even the
scientists wouldn't want to totally be
cut off from the other the other ways of
living right so politics becomes you
know you notice there is no like
political world all right
politics is something that this goes all
the way back to like you know Plato and
Aristotle and things like that politics
is something that can expands all of the
different human activities and
enterprises and I think you can you can
say it happens on like three main levels
in the stories you've got politics on
the underworlds so you know you've got
factions that form and fight each other
that's why they hire the door side or
hire the friendlies and you know there's
there's deliberations about what what
contracts are going to be like or where
where the priorities ought to go so
there's politics in that sense and you
could call that local politics in the
sense that it's local to a world and
then you have politics between the
worlds and you know the worlds will have
rivalries with each other or fight with
each other
they're associated into these two
eventually into these two sort of
leagues where you've got the tight
contracts and then the loose contracts
lined up with each other but then I
think there's also a higher level of
politics involved that the people on the
other two levels typically lose sight of
and you could call that the politics of
humanity in general and so some of the
characters like the william guy who
wants to rule all fourteen worlds he
he's carrying out things at that level
he's not just thinking in terms
making Kenny his world the most
important place he's not even really
that concerned about Kenny except as a
stepping stone to controlling and
everybody and so that I mean that's one
possibility for politics right and you
could also you could come up with all
sorts of justifications for that too
like hey it it's better to have one
person in charge because then
everybody's on the same plan and we're
not having all these inefficiencies it's
easy to come up with rationalizations
for that I think right but then there's
also these these characters that are
also doing politics on this grand scale
as well like the the Grahams that those
characters in the stories who are all
door side and are trying to you know at
first like make door sigh free and then
eventually you know make all of humanity
free and then there's there's other
characters too as the story goes on who
are not door silent they're from say
cold earth this whole this whole
development of the encyclopedia which is
such a vast project that when it's
completed it actually has to be put into
orbit because it can't exist on earth as
such and all of that I think you could
say is is like where is the race going
and how should things be the handle all
of that is a matter of this this grand
politics and I guess you know one of the
themes of the stories is the
interpenetration of these different
levels it's not like you can have grand
politics that doesn't have to take place
through the lower level of politics and
as I was thinking about this I was
thinking that I don't see any references
in any of the the things that I've read
by Dixon or about Dix and that talk
about Hegel but I think what he's doing
is in some respects very and galleon in
in a couple ways one one is the the
whole notion of an encyclopedia of human
knowledge to begin with though it would
be much faster than than Hegel's you
know it's cyclopædia logic right but the
idea behind an encyclopedia is that you
assemble all of the information and then
somebody who's smart enough can actually
make use of that and figure out what
ought to be done encyclopedia is not
just a reference tool it's not just a
putting things into boxes for the sake
of doing that it's something that's
supposed to allow us to have uh sort of
panoramic view and then come to
conclusions about where we ought to go
practical conclusions not just
theoretical conclusions I think that's
pretty hang Eliot Hagel also thought
that ideas really only become what they
are it's kind of interesting he's an
idealist right but he contrasts himself
against other idealists who don't grasp
that ideas have to become real in order
to truly be ideas things that are not
just material but spiritual can motivate
us but they have to take shape and when
they take shape
they always turn out different than we
thought and that's where the dialectic
comes in the dialectic is in part it's
not this you know thesis antithesis
synthesis thing that that people
portrayed us rather it's you have
something and it manifests itself it
appears as Hegel says and in doing so it
takes on determinacy and in doing so it
shows itself as being at odds with where
it came from this could be like you know
people abandoning
ideal seemingly in order to realize
their ideals but it has to become
determinate it has to become determinate
down to the level of connecting up with
individual human beings and their
desires and at the same time there's
there's larger you know like social
dynamics at play and that's that's what
gets you to a certain point now you can
reevaluate you can say well did this did
this work or not and sometimes in the
Galleon dialectic you actually have to
go back because it turns out while this
this actually didn't work out and I
think that's part of what's going on in
Dixon's novels this continual play of
the other thing is to at each like phase
you can't you can't predict what's
coming like a couple phases down the
line you know you as you could if like
everything was one complete system that
was all derived from axioms and then
just played it out right because human
beings as agents who reflect on
themselves and the meaning of their
lives and where they're involved in
history and what the conflicts are and
what matters because they make decisions
and communicate with each other history
is rich and it's not without meaning but
it's not something where it's got a
linear meaning where we can we can
neatly look at it and predict where
we're going so to think about some of
the questions that we're concerned with
about our own you know coming history
about what what what AI is going to mean
for us right we can we can extrapolate
this far but then we're not able to go
much further than that we need to get to
this point so we can actually think
through what's going on there and then
we can start thinking more more about
that
that's what the characters do it in this
book there you know he doesn't he
doesn't start out revealing the grand
plan in the first book and then just
have it play itself out where humanity's
evolution is going is gradually revealed
and I guess that makes sense because you
didn't think about he's writing these
stories over the course of 59 I mean
he's still working on this stuff when he
dies in 2001 yeah yeah seeing where the
story is going and this was this is part
supposed to be part of a larger story
actually well should we call it a story
some respects the words yeah yeah story
is too small in a way for that so
there's a few things that either Dickson
sadder were said about him he he said
that the child cycle said in order to
make this type of story work effectively
I developed by the late 1950s a new
fictional pattern that I've called the
consciously thematic story this was
specifically designed to create an
unconscious involvement of the reader
with the philosophic thematic argument
that the story action renders and
demonstrates because this new type of
story has represented a pattern hitherto
unknown to readers and writers my work
has been historic my work has
historically been criticized in terms
that do not apply to it primarily as if
it was drama alone so people would say
oh there's too much there's too much
talking talk you know about you know the
grand scheme her stuff like that
especially people said that about the
final encyclopedia story so that was a
common complaint but so his idea is that
I'm narrating this this vast
developmental
thing that has to do with where human
beings are going as a race and that's
that's what's really driving though the
whole thing so he's making an argument
and and the you know if you think about
it making an argument means that he's
putting this forth as one possibility
for us and saying this is this is how he
should conceive them things where this
is where we ought to go which implies
that there's many other possibilities
for where we could go right but the the
larger cycle was supposed to include
[Music]
some non science fiction books so the he
wanted to include some that would be
taking place in the 1300s and then there
was supposed to be another novel that
was going to deal with John Milton as a
faith holder and fanatic and then the
third one was supposed to be Robert
Browning and then there were going to be
three twentieth century novels as well
that interestingly enough we're going to
focus on the life and character George
Santayana in order to showcase the
Philosopher's then there was going to be
a world war two warrior and a female
faith holder in the 1980s that never
really came to pass and even the final
book antagonist had to be sort of
co-written and then published out of
notes with David Dixon later on in 2007
so the child cycles you know incomplete
but you know in a way if you think about
what he's doing as philosophy through
novels what that would imply then is
that we should look at this as sort of
like I mean whoever were some other
philosophers whose grand projects
they're they're incomplete but there's
enough of that where we're like yeah I
kind of get where this is going I mean
Hegel is one of them
I don't know that Heidegger really had
that much more to say after after you
know all the stuff that he already did
say maybe Nietzsche you know he lived or
if we possessed the stuff that we've
lost from Aristotle you know somebody
else would comes to my tewsbury theists
not so much because of his own writing
but because of the project that he had
which which is a civilization preserving
project so what we theas managed to
translate Plato's Timaeus and
Aristotle's categories and sophistic
reputations from from Greek into Latin
his goal was to translate everything
Plato wrote that he had access to and
everything that Aristotle wrote that he
had access to
had he lived you know much longer than
that he did because he his executors a
pretty young guy he probably would have
done that and then the history the
intellectual history of the West would
probably be quite quite different
wouldn't it but he wasn't able to do it
instead the the fragment of his project
did influence things quite a bit because
if you've got the tomatoes and you've
got what Cicero and Seneca and a few
other sources like Augustine are saying
about Plato you've actually got quite a
bit of Plato to work with but it's a
Plato that has a particular bent right
and if you've got Aristotle's categories
and sophistical reputations and then
again what's what's available in Cicero
and a few other authors you know you've
got enough to do some logic right even
before they recover the Aristotelian
text from the Arabs so you know it's and
I'm not saying that that's close to what
Dixon is doing I think Dixon's project
is more more brought off the
easiest this project but it's kind of
similar to that I mean if you think
about other philosopher novelists they
don't actually have that sort of
overarching scope in a lot of cases
think about Dostoevsky you know is there
any internal coherence between the
different big books Brothers Karamazov
the idiot the possessed Crime and
Punishment I mean there's themes but
there's no there's no like grand sweep
of this is where we're going as human
beings yeah yeah and people are
interpreting as a delayed aspect of his
vision of horror while this previous
film hereditary is like the nighttime
aspect okay so by doing multiple films
he's able to do more all-encompassing
yeah
where there's some sort of grand
overarching project that's unfolding you
know the other thing is - I imagine that
when you're doing that sort of thing
it's not like you have everything worked
out at the start all of your ideas that
you're like okay now how can i it's not
kind of move these pawns around to fit
them all in here right the process of
writing itself has to produce or the
process of filmmaking or whatever has
asked to not just unfold but also change
what you're what you're thinking of in
the process so maybe Nietzsche actually
is a better example somebody who's
closer
the only other theme that I thought was
particularly apt to bring up is it has
to do with history and you know in the
well in the middle books and then in the
later books there's this final
encyclopedia and it's taking place on
earth and the idea like I mentioned is
you put together all the information on
human history and you'll be able to
figure out what's going on and it's
clear that we you know we're not you
know doomed simply to repeat history
like Santiago said you know because
there's there's the flipside of that
those who do remember history maybe
they're not just doomed to repeat it
over and over again but how do we learn
from history you know sometimes it's
like well we shouldn't fall you know
don't don't fight a two-front war you
know or don't invade Russia all right
those are the kind of things that people
draw as corollaries or you know when we
worry about fascism rising here in the
United States you know we say you know
putting these
these camps are really a bad idea
because you know look at where that goes
later on but I think that there's that's
all sort of like it's not big picture
history in a sense it's not like where
is the human race going so when we again
if we think about Hegel or we think
about Nietzsche there are these deep
reflections what is the human what is
the human race or the human being you
know writ large becoming and a lot of
that has to do with what we what we make
of our own past and our analysis and the
present and our ideas about the
possibilities from where we can go and
and having some sort of discourse with
with others not just you know like
deciding in my own head you know like
like some grand you know ruler where
everything should go but but figuring
out with other human beings where it
should go further so perhaps it's it's
impossible to avoid politics you know
maybe if we are going to learn something
from history in that way it has to be
something that we do collaboratively
rather than it's like but encyclopedias
to know was it all right and then
decides for all all humanity but you
know this this notion of having a final
encyclopedia it's kind of a it's kind of
an interesting idea how would it ever be
final you know
could we could we successfully get all
the stuff together and then once you've
done that well who the hell is going to
actually work through all of this stuff
in a lifetime and make sense of it does
that mean is it just like a plot device
you think to drive the story forward in
that case or yeah that's a factor and
then you know a human being will forget
a lot too so you know like I haven't
there are some authors when I've read
pretty much all that they've written but
I'd forgotten most of what I've read and
that's just an author that's not like
you know human human kind all all
together so yeah so maybe you know maybe
it is just a plot device or maybe it
would require something like going back
and having some vast computer system
that would would analyze it but then
you'd be in the problematic of the
computer that decides get rid of human
beings there they're actually just
but you know they're they're jamming up
the gears so to speak the problem with
the computer system is he articulates it
and necromancer is that it doesn't have
that reflexivity capacity it can't
actually tell when its own thinking is
off base or drawing on the wrong
principles and it can't it can't really
understand what human beings are like
only human beings could understand what
human beings are like so I think that
that's probably a good place to end
we've rambled over quite a bit anything
you want to say to bring it to a close
do you think maybe he did that he's not
distracted and I'm wondering if he drew
on some of the same research because he
was gonna write a medieval book for the
historical right yeah so 13 hundredths
yeah that's about the period when the
dragon on the gorge takes place man
right so he might have drawn on the same
resources he might have found that tiger
and so interest and then he decided I
need to write
this serious - yeah and if you hadn't
written those you know you spend a lot
less philosophical the characters are
still intelligent there's some
interesting thought-provoking bits yeah
I don't remember there being some humor
in there - oh yeah
even the title the dragon of the gorge
is kind of a joke yeah yeah it's been
it's been such a long time since I they
were fun how long ago - jus read them
okay I'll say this then sort of started
to conclude you know sometimes when we
go back to these these series like I
read some of these door sightings when I
was a teenager and I liked him I
definitely didn't get what the hell was
going on in the books and I'm always
worried when we go back to these that
I'm going to be disappointed like you
know the Piers Anthony yeah it's okay
you know Michael Moorcock you know this
is actually I'm I'm looking forward to
you know doing more with with Dixon when
I have the time because of this sort of
vast historical sweep that he's got in
there and the introduction of philosophy
without without going into like bringing
in a lot of philosophers it's quite
interesting stuff so I was really
pleased reading
this to find something I can sink my
teeth into like well thanks for another
good conversation
[Music]
you